>> Tucker: TRACE GALLAGHER,
THANKS SO MUCH FOR THAT.
FROM EARLY ON IN THIS CRISIS, WE
TOOK THE VIRUS SERIOUSLY BUT WE
DOUBTED THE CHINESE STYLE
LOCKDOWN.
EVEN IF THEY WORKED AS
ADVERTISED AS YOU JUST HEARD
THERE IS NO OVERWHELMING
EVIDENCE THAT THEY DON’T WORK AS
ADVERTISED, DESPITE WHAT
POLITICIANS CONTINUE TO SAY,
MASS QUARANTINES UNDER THE BEST
OF CIRCUMSTANCES ARE REALLY JUST
A STOPGAP.
THE ONLY WAY TO TAME A VIRUS
LIKE THIS IS WITH SCIENCE.
A SINGLE EFFECTIVE TREATMENT
WOULD MAKE ALL THE DIFFERENCE,
RIGHT AWAY.
YOU WOULDN’T HAVE TO CURE EVERY
SICK PATIENT, BUT IF YOU COULD
CURE A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF
SICK PATIENTS AND LOWER THE
DEATH RATE, THIS WOULD BE A
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT COUNTRY.
HOPE WOULD RETURN.
FEAR WOULD RECEDE, WE COULD
BEGIN TO REGARD THIS AS A
MANAGEABLE ILLNESS AS WE DO SO
MANY OTHER ILLNESSES.
MORE THAN 600,000 AMERICANS DIED
FROM CANCER THIS YEAR, THAT IS A
TRAGIC NUMBER.
BUT WE ACCEPT IT, AND WE LIVE
OUR LIVES BRIEFLY IN THE FACE OF
IT IN PART BECAUSE CANCER,
HORRIBLE AS IT IS, ISN’T VERY
MYSTERIOUS ANYMORE.
THERE ARE TREATMENTS FOR IT.
THOSE TREATMENTS SADLY DON’T
ALWAYS WORK, BUT THEY WORKED
OFTEN ENOUGH THAT WE CAN LIVE
WITHOUT PANIC.
IT’S BEEN OBVIOUS FROM DAY ONE
HERE THAT THE MAIN GOAL HAS GOT
TO BE FINDING EFFECTIVE
TREATMENTS FOR THE VIRUS, THAT’S
OBVIOUS AND MOST PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND IT INTUITIVELY.
ONE OF THE FIRST OFF LABEL DRUGS
THAT DOCTORS AROUND AROUND THE W
USED TO TREAT THE CORONAVIRUS
WAS A MEDICINE CALLED HYDROXYL
CHLOROQUINE.
HYDROXYL CHLOROQUINE IS A CHEAP,
DECADES-OLD MEDICINE LONG
RECOGNIZED AS A THERAPEUTIC FOR
LUPUS AND ARTHRITIS, AUTOIMMUNE
DISEASES, IT WAS ORIGINALLY AN
ANTIMALARIA DRUG.
IF YOU TRAVEL TO THE THIRD
WORLD, IT IS ENTIRELY POSSIBLE
YOU HAVE ALREADY TAKEN THIS DRUG
DRUG.
EARLY EVIDENCE SUGGESTED THAT IT
MIGHT BE PROMISING, POSITIONS IN
THE HARDEST HIT COUNTRIES LIKE
SPAIN AND ITALY REPORTED THAT IT
WAS THEIR PREFERRED TREATMENT
FOR THE CORONAVIRUS.
THE PRESIDENT COUNT OF THE DRUG
IS A PROMISING LEAD.
THAT WAS IT FOR HYDROXYL
CHLOROQUINE.
FROM THAT MOMENT ON, PRECISELY
THAT MOMENT IN THE MINDS OF
PARTISAN IN OUR MEDIA
ESTABLISHMENT,
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE WAS PURELY A
POLITICAL ISSUE.
THE DRUG WAS NO LONGER A
MEDICINE OR THERAPY, IT WAS THE
MEDICAL EQUIVALENT OF
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
THEY COULD SWING IT IN THE AIR
MINDLESSLY TO HIT THEIR
IDEOLOGICAL OPPONENTS IN THE
HELP OF POLITICAL GAIN.
THEY IGNORED EVIDENCE THAT IT
MIGHT BE EFFECTIVE IN SOME WAYS,
THEY WAITED ANXIOUSLY FOR
EVIDENCE THAT IT MIGHT NOT BE.
THE OTHER DAY THEY GOT IT.
SEVERAL RECENT STUDIES SUGGEST
THAT HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE IS
UNLIKELY TO HELP PEOPLE WHO ARE
ALREADY SEVERELY ILL WITH THE
CORONAVIRUS.
FOR MOST AMERICANS, THIS WAS
DISAPPOINTING NEWS.
THEY WANTED IT TO WORK.
BUT AT CNN, IT WAS CAUSE FOR
CELEBRATION.
THE NETWORK PRODUCED A VIDEO FOR
ITS WEBSITE TALLYING UP EVERY
TIME THE PRESIDENT HAD MENTIONED
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE.
>> A DRUG CALLED
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE, CHLOROQUINE.
CHLOROQUINE, HYDROXY CORGAN.
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE.
CHLOROQUINE.
A LOT OF GOOD THINGS ARE
HAPPENING WITH IT, A LOT OF GOOD
TESTS.
>> OVER AT
"THE WASHINGTON POST," WHICH SO
OFTEN SEEM TO WORK IN TANDEM
WITH CNN, A PERSON CALLED PHILIP
A BUMP PRODUCED A 3,000 WORD
LONG TIMELINE LOOKING AT THE
RISE AND FALL OF TRUMP’S
OBSESSION WITH
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE.
BUMP HIMSELF OBSESSIVELY
CHRONICLED EVERY TIME THE
PRESIDENT SO MUCH AS RETWEETED A
MESSAGE OF THE DRUG.
HE LOCKED THE PRECISE NUMBER OF
TIMES THAT HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE
WAS MENTIONED ON THIS CHANNEL
AND ON FOX BUSINESS.
PAGING DR. FREUD.
IT’S POSSIBLE THAT MR. BUMP MAY
BE EXHIBITING SYMPTOMS OF
OBSESSION.
HE WROTE YET ANOTHER ARTICLE ON
THE SAME TOPIC, AND I DID THAT
PIECE WITH THE SUGGESTION OF A
SINISTER CONSPIRACY AT WORK.
WHY PROMOTE THAT DRUG AND WHY SO
ENERGETICALLY?
AND HE LET THE QUESTION HANG IN
THE AIR.
PHILIP BUMP DOESN’T BELIEVE IN
HUMAN OPTIMISM, HE ALWAYS
ASSUMES A SECRET AGENDA.
BUT AS USUAL, THIS WAS PURE
PROJECTION.
WHAT BIG MEDIA ACCUSES YOU OF
DOING A PHYSICAL TIME, THEY ARE
FERVENTLY DOING THEMSELVES.
THEY’RE THE ONES OBSESSED WITH
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE.
MOST PEOPLE JUST WANT A DRUG
THAT WORKS.
THEY’RE THE ONES WITH A WEIRD
UNSPOKEN AGENDA, OBVIOUS AND YET
HIDDEN.
MOST PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY JUST
WANT A DRUG THAT WORKS, IN FACT,
IN SOME CIRCUMSTANCES THIS MAY
WORK.
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE IS STILL
BEING USED TO TREAT CORONAVIRUS
PATIENTS.
DOZENS OF STUDIES OF ITS
EFFECTIVENESS ARE NOW IN
PROGRESS, STILL AT THIS HOUR.
MANY DOCTORS BELIEVE IT CAN HELP
IF USED EARLY OR IN MILD CASES
OF THE DISEASE.
THE VA SECRETARY RECENTLY SAID
AS MUCH.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS TOUTED
THIS, BUT IT IS LINKED TO HIGHER
RATES OF DEATH IN THE VA.
CAN YOU ELABORATE, WHAT IS GOING
ON WITH THIS DRUG?
>> SURE, THAT’S AN OBSERVATIONAL
STUDY NOT A CLINICAL STUDY.
IT WAS DONE ON A SMALL NUMBER OF
VETERANS.
SADLY, THOSE OF WHOM WERE IN THE
LAST STAGES OF LIFE.
THE DRUG WAS GIVEN TO THEM, AND
I HAVE TO ALSO SAY THAT THE
DRUG, WE KNOW THE DRUG HAS BEEN
WORKING ON MIDDLE AGE AND
YOUNGER VETERANS.
>> Tucker: OH, SO CORRELATION
IS NOT CAUSATION.
THESE ARE DEEP WATERS.
MANY PEOPLE ON TELEVISION ARE
NOT PREPARED, THEY ARE NOT
WEARING THEIR SWIMSUITS.
IN REAL LIFE, WE ARE GETTING
MIXED RESULTS.
WE NEED TO KNOW MORE.
THIS IS HOW SCIENCE ACTUALLY
WORKS.
IT’S WHY WE STILL HAVEN’T CURED
CANCER, DESPITE DECADES OF
WORKING ON IT.
BUT WE HAVE PROLONGED THE LIVES
OF CANCER PATIENTS
SIGNIFICANTLY, THAT’S A VICTORY.
THESE ARE THE KINDS OF VICTORIES
YOU GET IN THIS BUSINESS, REAL
SCIENCE IS COMP LOCATED.
AND DIFFICULT, AND ALMOST ALWAYS
INCREMENTAL.
THE PARTY OF SCIENCE NO LONGER
UNDERSTANDS THAT BECAUSE THEY
LEFT SCIENCE A LONG TIME AGO,
KAREN WINSTON IS A DEMOCRATIC
LAWMAKER IN THE STATE OF
MICHIGAN, SHE BELIEVES SHE WAS
SUFFERING FROM CORONAVIRUS AND
GETTING WORSE UNTIL SHE RECEIVED
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE FROM HER
POSITION.
THEN SHE RECOVERED.
SHE CAME ON THE SHOW TO RECLAIM
WHAT HAPPENED, AS SHE CLEANED IT
SHE GAVE SOME CREDIT TO A
PRESIDENT SHE DID NOT VOTE FOR.
>> AFTER A WHILE, IT DID SAVE MY
LIFE AND I DID CREDIT THE
PRESIDENT FOR DOING SO.
IN PUTTING THIS OUT THERE, IT
WASN’T ACCESSIBLE BEFORE THAT.
I HAD VERY LITTLE TIME TO BE
ABLE TO GET TO THIS AND BE ABLE
TO MAKE IMPROVEMENTS, MY
BREATHING DID BECOME VERY
LABORED.
>> Tucker: YOU SO I WOMAN WHO
AT BARE MINIMUM WENT THROUGH A
HARROWING EXPERIENCE AND ESCAPED
WITH HER LIFE, WE SHOULD
CELEBRATE BUT NOT EVERYBODY ELSE
ELSE.
THEY DIDN’T CONGRATULATE HER FOR